sur y este de ucrania aquí se está
concentrando la guerra en esta jornada
de hoy un ataque ha afectado a una zona
cercana a la planta nuclear de sap
orilla recordemos que esta
infraestructura es la más grande de
europa está bajo control ruso desde el
pasado mes de marzo y este incidente se
produce después de las palabras del
ministro de relaciones exteriores de
rusia quien dijo que el conflicto
nuclear es un peligro real para el mundo
también hay informaciones de pequeños
avances de las tropas rusas en algunos
pueblos del este de más ataques en el
sur y en el noreste y en el sur en la
región de odessa esta estratégica región
del sur de ucrania las autoridades han
denunciado el lanzamiento de un misil
que habría afectado un puente de esta
zona la guerra por tanto continúa en
este país y también sigue afectando a su
economía que cada día más sufre las
consecuencias de este conflicto según
los últimos datos del país producirá al
menos un 20% menos granos este año con
respecto al año anterior y esto ocurre
en un país que es considerado el granero
de europa